he is Chris Mad Dog rusev how are you
Christopher mr. Eisen how you doing big
guy okay better for chatting with you
better for chatting with you you know
you were all over that billing bill ESPN
documentary with the early look way back
in nineteen whatever it may have been
1998 did you see that what do you mean
by early look what are you seeing you
look handsome you look like a 24 year
old kid out of Staten Island he looks
tremendous well actually I have yet to
see it it's been sitting on my DVR it
was the FRA think they aired it the
Friday before Super Bowl 52 so I was you
know out and about I haven't seen it yet
but all I know is like my Twitter feed
was filled with photographs and screen
grabs I thought they did a 30 for 30 on
my hairline quite frankly yeah that's
possible but it was good you came across
well okay first of all my my my little
cockamamie idea was an idea that was
proposed to me in a social setting by a
major league baseball executive of note
saying to me what do you think of this
idea I'm like well that would definitely
inflame a bunch of traditionalists but
it's interesting can I say it on my air
this executive said not yet when all the
rules came out this past week that seems
to be ready for 2018 play about the the
mound visits and all that I emailed the
executives saying can I say it on the
air and the executives said go ahead so
what do you think of this idea terrible
ideas something different I mean I you
know the idea of course is that you the
team's feeling in the night getting home
or away can pick their lineup what they
want up is that what is that well we're
basically anybody who's trailing in the
ninth inning whether you're the away
team and needing to push it to the
bottom of the ninth or extras or you're
in the bottom of the ninth you're the
home team you could put up whoever you
want to bat the first three the first
three in the order at the in the ninth
inning anybody you know it's not a
terrible idea baseball's trying to do
everything they can as you know better
than anybody I'm sprucing up their
offense you know you know
there with the advent of the reliever
and how good a pitcher is and all the
strikeouts they're trying to create a
little excitement almost like the NBA
going a half-court you know with the
last second shot call the timeout
advance the ball which they never used
to do into you know 20 years ago they
want to have some excitement at the end
and they're trying to jazz it up and
figure out a way to combat the accent of
the great relief pitcher and find a
little zest and a little offense so
highlight material in the ninth inning
so it's not a terrible idea now they're
never going to do it right but it's not
a terrible idea I mean it's
brainstorming they've come up with a lot
of crazy things you we all know about
the X winnings so it's men on first and
second or whatever it was we saw that
during the World Baseball Classic so
they're trying to come up with a meme a
can to create more rallies in the last
three innings of this game of these
games and so that right there is
probably a couple cocktails all the
executives hanging around on Park Avenue
what could we do to Rich Eisen he can
get the world and they succeeded and
it's an again you know what I give you
credit that's that's it's something
interesting something different I would
not balk at that now again our baseball
so stuck in tradition they won't do it
but it's not a terrible idea I said it
earlier in the show I'll tell you that
this is not from what I found out
yesterday it's not close to even close
to fruition I mean it's this is just an
idea that's being thrown out there by an
executive with some juice to try and
juice things up I guess when everybody's
sitting around about what can be done
and I guess that's the ultimate thing is
that is that there is constant
conversation about what can be done do
you think something needs to be done yes
I do I think the biggest issue I have
with the sport right now rich as far as
a dead time and the length of games and
you know the lack of offense outside of
hitting the ball out of the ballpark is
the advent of the relief pitcher I think
that is the biggest problem that we have
why was that used in Yankee series so
much fun it's in certain regards because
Verlander had a pitched as great as he
did to keep the Astros in the mix in
games 2 & 6
oh you need the big star to have to
fight his way through these
the Kershaw's of the world seventh
eighth ninth and that's why bum Gordon
was a lot of fun and with so many great
relievers anonymous relievers who you
and I have never heard of who you know
pitch the one batter and so one hundred
miles an hour and strike him out with
three pitches and then the managers got
to go out there take him out of the game
bring another reliever in and this goes
on and on and on especially in September
when these bullpens are fortified by
their minor leaguers and a game's drag
and there's no offense and always here
is a bunch of strikeouts because of the
great reliever and I think that needs to
be combatted so how they do that I would
suggest making sure at least a little
step that every time you bring a
reliever in he has to face two batters
instead of just one interesting you know
at least eliminates the idea of the
lefty specialist where if he comes in to
face two lefty and such say Bryce Harper
he's got to stay in here to face Lyons
Zimmerman I mean please put a little
strategy into the whole situation now
what do they do that
we all saw how hard it was just to get
this silly mound visits incorporate into
the sport if they can ever get that
through the Players Association that
would be something I would before Kris
mad dog Russo of Mad Dog Sports Radeon
serious in high heat on MLB Network here
on the Rich Eisen show ask him a poll
question that was born out Brockman last
night of the the gold medal game that
came down in women's hockey to a
shootout yeah I don't like that
go for it Chris yeah I don't like that
already have our answer yeah I don't
like that now listen they played 440
overtime correct yes right okay so they
took the one skater I don't even like
that I don't like those gimmicks in in
knockout play in the Olympics I don't
mind doing it me in the qualifying stage
there's first three games I don't like
to do it a knockout play now again I
went to bed answered the first period
because East Coast that I installed at
11:10 so I did not see the game live so
I can't you know I'm not sure how I
would have felt watching it but I know
it's almost a little bit like the soccer
the World Cup soccer which goes on and
on and they do the shootout well
I don't I don't like that I would have
played until they dropped and scored a
goal normally in that situation so
that's the poll question is who's got
the best overtime college football pro
football you got you've got obviously
it's a good poll question sovereign
walking I would say pro football you
like pro football because I think yeah
the gimmicky was college football
I like pro football the NFL rich because
you know it gives the defense they have
they they can it rewards the offense for
scoring a touchdown and it gives the
other team's offense a chance if it's
just a field goal I like that a lot in
the NFL I think they do a good job in
the NFL you should not get the ball back
like the Falcons if you can't stop the
team from scoring a touchdown I think
they have the best system the World Cup
soccer I don't like at all I don't think
you decide these World Cup games by by
shootouts I know that's a little
trickier because it's harder to score
goals in soccer but I do not like
settling gold medal games and hockey
they play one meaningful game every four
years you gotta settle down a shootout I
don't like that at all a couple more
minutes with Mad Dog Russo what do you
think of the idea of Kirk Cousins in New
York you were obviously know what it's
like to I don't which I don't think
that's a good idea reader first off this
is a guy who has never won a playoff
game who when he's had a couple of
chances late in the season to steer his
team into the postseason Carolina Giants
two years ago he was outplayed by
Rodgers which is not the worst thing in
that Green Bay playoff game he has not
responded
you cannot give him thirty million
dollars a year on his jet team
especially with the Jets with the sixth
pick who are going to get a quarterback
in some capacity I mean whether it's
Baker Mayfield AJ McCarron somebody from
the Vikings I mean three guys who are
coming out and Alan Rosen and Donald
somewhere along the line if they do
their work right they're gonna get a
good college quarterback or a good
backup in the NFL to spend 30-something
million dollars on a guy who let's be
honest it's not top ten in the league he
is not a top ten quarterback I
understand the prices of quarterbacks
that's what it is
I get it you have to have one I get that
I would not do that upon the Jets to be
honest he's never won a playoff game
rich for crying out loud I know and then
all he's got to do is just throw have
one to pick game up a New England and
and then it's just a quarterback 34
million dollars so I don't know where
Cousins is I don't know why cousins
would go to the Jets either I mean he's
got the Giants across the street he's
got so Brady and Belichick to worry
about the Jets don't have a great
history I would even be surprised that's
where he'd want to go but if our the jet
organization I know the fans want Amanda
worse whether they want to QB I will not
go near him myself
if I was him I'd want to go to Denver go
to do the same thing the or Athena would
make you a little nervous about that for
Denver is he's kind of following Peyton
Manning and you know maybe he doesn't
want to be compared to him
Arizona wouldn't be a bad place either
that's true good weather Fitzgerald
David Johnson put a decent defense you
know that wouldn't be the worst place
either last a last one for you Chris I
had John Smoltz on the show last week we
talked about you know Dodgers Yankees
Houston etc the usuals and then said
don't sleep on the San Francisco Giants
what do you think about your Giants yeah
I think that's a good possibility I
think if you look at it right now rich
there are only seven teams in baseball
right this second that barring something
nutty really have a chance to win a
World Series seven you know the
Nationals the Cubs the Dodgers Houston
is for Cleveland five Yankees and Red
Sox is seven I maybe you want to add the
Mets or something but I'll say seven and
as eight teams as the wild-card round I
still got a chance so why can't one of
those teams be San Francisco they do
have the two big pitchers at the top of
the rotation you got to figure Melanson
will come back and pitch pretty well you
know Lynn Gloria should be motivated you
bring in McCutchen playing for her
contract pose he's still sitting there
the coming off a lousy season it's a
hard division but I don't they got a
good manager too I don't know I think
the Giants would be pretty good I agree
with that and then you know in the Met
rotation all they needed some offense
maybe Tebow could provide it based on my
Tebow now is gonna be in the major
leagues
that's ridiculous Oh what is this a
carnival act here's what I'll take the
Met seriously about Tebow yes when they
disallow him the work of the
see see network with college football
when they say you may not be with Paul
Finebaum I want you I want you an
instructional league hmm that's what
I'll take them seriously I want you
looking I want you in Port st. Lucie
training I don't want you doing games on
weekends with the FCC that's what I'll
take them out seriously that they think
the TiVo can go out there and help them
who else's I'm going on vacation Sunday
which I'm looking forward to it where
you going I'm going to Grenada huh down
in the Caribbean really I was going to
visit you in California but I didn't get
the invite Chris please it's a standing
invitation I didn't go I left summer
went to Laguna and I stated that montage
and now and I texted your producers and
everything and not any feedback that
disturbed me that cannot be true Chris
that is Richard Christopher all right
now I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have to
have an organizational meeting of the
Rich Eisen show we're gonna get this
thing done and then and then we're gonna
pass this rule in Major League Baseball
I like that my daughter might go to USC
so I'll be out there a lot maybe you
still have a cup of coffee with me one
plate that's it Chris Chris dan
Patrick's two kids went to USC one yes
and they have a substituted on occasion
as babysitter's in my house from my my
wife and I feed that have fed the
Patrick children for years and years and
years let's keep going let's keep it
going
let's keep it going let's do it Chris
okay sent to you crystal cable all right
Christopher there's Christopher Mad Dog
Russo here on the Rich Eisen the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience